[MUSIC PLAYING]
TEI SHI: All right.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Tei Shi.
This is Bobby.
We're going to be playing
some songs for you today.
Thank you for having us in.
This is really cool.
Your office is kind of insane.
In the best way possible.
All right, we're going to
start with a song called
"Keep Running."
[GUITAR PLAYING]
(SINGING) Every time I look over
my shoulder, I'm getting older.
I'm getting older.
Every time I look over my
shoulder, I'm getting older.
I'm getting older.
Time is so sad.
Tie me to it.
Strapped to my side.
Never look back.
Baby, keep running.
Keep running for me.
Chasing the things that
you see in your sleep.
Baby, keep running,
keep running for me.
Don't hesitate.
Don't make me wait.
If you want my loving, then
you better start running.
If you want my loving,
then you better start.
Every time I look over my
shoulder, I'm getting older.
I'm getting older.
Time is so sad.
Tie me to it.
Strapped to my side.
Never look back.
Baby, keep running.
Keep running for me.
If you keep on running,
if you keep on running,
chasing the things that
you see in your sleep.
If you're chasing things,
if you're chasing things,
baby, keep running,
keep running for me.
Keep on running,
baby, keep on running.
Don't hesitate.
Don't make me wait.
If you want my loving,
if you want my loving.
Baby, keep running,
keep running for me.
If you keep on running,
baby, keep on running for me.
If you're chasing things, if
you're chasing things in your
sleep.
If you keep on running,
if you keep on running,
don't hesitate.
Don't make me wait.
If you want my loving, then
you better start running.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
Thank you.
It's awesome to be here.
We played a show
last night as part
of Noise Pop, which is going on,
I think, all week in the city.
And I love this city.
It's really great to play here.
So I'm glad we were able to come
in today and play for you guys.
Thank you for being here.
We're going to do
another song now.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
(SINGING) Baby, why
you trying to blame me?
Even though I'm
drying up on patience,
you know I'm the same me.
Maybe we could try doing
something fun tonight.
We both know we're
running out of secrets.
Only in the daylight we thrive.
Listen here.
If you don't look at
me, I'll disappear.
We can end this now with
a full house, take a bow,
and shed a single tear.
Oh, dear.
But hold me close.
And we can dance to the violins.
Let me know.
I want to go down in silence.
It's not personal.
Just wish I could
reverse it all.
Give me something good,
and send a wink my way.
If it hurts at all,
I'll start to fall.
Sit tight.
And dream about me all night.
Take a dive and swim
inside a memory.
Say everything is all right.
Oh, my.
Oh, whoa.
If you're in there, just
know that I am not scared.
I'll take you by the
shoulder, squeeze them tight,
and shake you till I break you.
Hey, you.
To lose you is something
I refuse to do.
If everything's
a choice in life,
just like they say,
well then, I choose you.
Do, do.
Hold me close.
And we can dance
with the violins.
Let me know.
I want to go down in silence.
Silence.
Ah, ah, ah.
And we can dance
with the violins.
Let me know.
I'll go down in silence.
Silence.
Baby, whoa, baby.
Whoa, baby.
You know I'm the same me, baby.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
That song is called "Baby."
Thank you.
I think we're doing some
interview stuff now.
SPEAKER 1: A few questions.
A few questions for you.
Once again, thank
you for being here.
I think if we can give
another round of applause.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
So these are songs
off your new album
that came out about a year ago.
And you just finished a tour.
You came to San Francisco
just to do Noise Pop, which
is completely awesome.
But what was the progression
to make this album, which
is "Crawl Space"?
TEI SHI: Yeah, yeah.
So all these songs that
we're playing today
are off my debut album,
which came out, yeah,
almost a year ago.
And the album was kind of
a culmination of a couple
of years of writing.
I had put out two
EPs before the album,
and that's kind of
how I started out.
I put out an EP of
songs I had written
when I was at music school.
And just kind of threw
them online and kind of got
into that online
blog world as it was,
I think, kind of at its end.
And yeah.
And then I made a second
EP and just kind of started
playing live and really getting
used to this whole performance
and actually putting music
out for other people to hear.
And so the album was kind of--
it's 12 songs and I spent
about a year and a half
to two years writing it right
after the second EP came out.
And it's really just kind of
the emotional journey, I think,
of going from putting
my music out there,
and starting from a very naive
place and a very kind of just
DIY place, and then kind
of being thrown very
quickly into that experience of
having other people listening
and judging, and other
people's opinions,
and getting used to
the music industry,
and working with other people
and just a lot of my ups
and downs through that process.
And so the album kind of deals
with all of those emotions
and also a breakup that
happened around the time
I was finishing the album.
And so there's some love
songs, and there's just
a lot of self-reflection
on it and a mix
of a lot of different sounds
and genres that I listen to.
I like to listen to all
kinds of different music,
so it's pretty eclectic.
This is kind of a very different
arrangement of the songs, just
the guitar and vocals.
But if you listen
to the recordings,
they're much more built out.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
It's a great album.
I don't know why I'm
bending over so much.
No, it's a great album.
And "Crawl Space"
actually has to do
with that coming out in there
and finding that safe space,
as you said.
TEI SHI: Yeah.
The album title, "Crawl
Space," was kind of
inspired by a couple of things.
It's symbolically a crawl space.
It's this very small place
in your house that's cramped
and not a very nice
space to be in.
But I think,
emotionally, that idea
of a really small,
cramped space was
kind of how I felt
when I was working
on the album and dealing with
some kind of relationships
around me crumbling, and just
really having to reassess
my life and my surroundings
as I was actually making music
my career, and all
the difficulties that
come with that.
And the crawl space also
has a double meaning for me,
because when I
was really little,
my family moved from Colombia to
Canada when I was about eight.
And we moved into a
house for the first time,
and it had this
crawl space in it,
which I'd never known
what that was before,
but I was really afraid of it.
And I had a really
hard time at night--
a lot of anxiety in the
nighttime and insomnia.
And so I developed
this ritual of forcing
myself to sit in the crawl space
for a minute every night just
to kind of confront my fears.
And then over the course of
the first year of being there,
I got over those night
fears and that fear.
And so that was a
lesson to myself.
I learnt to confront my
anxieties and my fears really
just head on to deal with them.
And making the album was
very much a process of that.
I was really afraid
of this daunting idea
of putting out an album and
really presenting myself
as an artist to people.
And so the album was
a process of dealing
with those fears and
those insecurities
and coming out on the
other end feeling really
proud and confident about it.
SPEAKER 1: I got to ask then.
Is the tarantula real
that's on your face on the--
TEI SHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That's
a real tarantula?
TEI SHI: Yeah.
So the album cover and all
the artwork on the album is--
it's my face with
a tarantula on it.
And that was another fear of
mine, as I'm sure most of you
can relate.
I just thought it
was a really, first
of all, like a cool visual,
because the album title "Crawl
Space," I wanted to play off
of that very visceral, kind
of creepy, the word "crawl."
And so I thought of a tarantula,
which really scared me
at first, but I always
like a challenge.
And I thought the visual
would be really amazing
and that there were some
images that I was inspired by.
There's this Michael
Jackson "Time" cover where
he has a tarantula on his face.
And so I saw that
and I was just like,
yes, this is the
look that I want.
But it was a real tarantula.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Yeah, I could understand
that would be scary.
TEI SHI: Yes.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 1: So you mentioned
you moved from Colombia,
but you were born
in Buenos Aires.
Lived in Colombia,
moved to Canada.
You also said-- and I was
talking about this earlier
about the Shakira thing,
where you mentioned about one
of your favorite albums growing
up was Shakira's second CD.
I always forget its
name, because it's--
TEI SHI: Yeah.
Well, there were a
couple of her early CDs.
SPEAKER 1: That
you really liked.
And when you describe
them, you say
it was like an early Alanis
Morissette, which I thought was
a very Canadian thing to say.
But since then, you moved.
Then you lived in New
York, and now you're in LA.
Being in all these
areas, how has that
really changed your
sound and influenced
what you're doing today?
TEI SHI: I mean, I think
changing your surroundings
and your environment is the
main thing, at least for me.
I think the main thing you can
do to really just keep yourself
stimulated, and
discovering who you are
and what things stay constant
when you change everything
around you, and what things
about you are really adaptable,
and I think that
that's something really
important to do creatively.
In music, for sure,
I think experiencing
different cultures, different
languages, different genres
of music, different
ways of making music,
ways of performing.
So for me, now
being able to travel
and moving around at this
point is really important.
And it's just something
I grew up doing as well.
Yeah, I was born in Argentina.
My parents are Colombian.
And when I was two, we
moved back to Colombia
and lived there until I was
eight, and then went to Canada.
And since then,
I kind of grew up
in between Colombia and Canada.
So I feel very much Colombian
and very much Canadian.
And I think that's just
kind of part of my identity,
just like feeling very
multi-faceted, I guess,
in my background.
And that's the way I like
to approach music too.
SPEAKER 1: So when you
say you started off
putting your music
out there, I noticed
that a lot of your early
shows were big festivals,
like Coachella, and with some
pretty cool bands like Jungle,
who is amazing and
all that stuff.
And now you're going
on your own tours.
How's that, knowing that people
now are here solely to see you?
TEI SHI: Yeah.
It's a pretty weird experience.
Yeah, I started
playing live really
just as a tool to help
get my music out there.
And then I was really
lucky with my second EP,
to be able to tour
quite a bit off of that,
and do festivals, and support
some really awesome bands
and artists.
So that kind of got
me just, I guess,
into the idea of standing
in front of people
and being able to gauge also
what things connect with people
in a live environment.
And festivals are very
different from venue shows,
and club shows are different.
So all of these situations,
they require, I think,
experience, just to know
what to bring to the table
and what kind of set to
build around the songs.
And so by the time
I made the album
and did the tour
around the album,
I was able to have a better
sense of what that's like,
and know what I wanted
the show to be like,
and how I wanted the
audience to feel.
Yeah, but it's a
pretty surreal thing.
We did a really long
two-month tour in the fall.
It ended in the end of October.
And we toured quite a
bit throughout last year.
So this show we did last
night was the first show we
played in months.
And it's really kind of crazy
to just come to San Francisco,
and play a show, and see that
there's a bunch of people there
and they know the songs.
That is the thing that
just never fully clicks--
the idea that what you're
making and putting out
there is actually something
that people are connecting with
and that they want to come see.
I always feel, before a show,
no one's going to show up.
And I just don't understand
why this happens.
But it's really amazing.
It's so much fun,
and it's really
fulfilling, especially
cities like San Francisco,
where the energy's
always really great.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I think the
first song I heard of yours
was off of one of your EPs.
And we talked to-- it's a song
which everyone should look up.
It's a little racy,
but it's "Sickasfuck."
It's a great song.
And then you come out with
songs like "Keep On Running,"
which is beautiful.
And I've seen many different
acoustic versions you've done,
which has just
been crazy vocals.
What's next?
You just finished this
album, a year passed.
Are you working on new stuff?
Or where are you going?
TEI SHI: Yeah.
So I actually just moved
over to the West Coast,
so now I'm a Californian
just like you guys.
SPEAKER 1: LA, though.
TEI SHI: [LAUGHS] You got
to blow my cover like that?
Yeah.
Yes, I'm working on new music.
And we're continuing
to play the album
and continuing to
get that out there.
But trying to just
write some new music,
and figure out what the
next project will be,
and just collaborate
with different people.
Yeah, that's kind
of the next-- yeah.
I mean, I'm hoping to get some
new music out soon and just
keep people interested.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 1: Where do you go
to find this inspiration?
Are you a movie watcher?
Do you go to a whole
bunch of shows yourself?
Do you just like to
wander in the woods?
TEI SHI: I think it's a
combination of a lot of things.
I think, like in anything,
in anything anybody does,
you pick up little bits of
influence or inspiration
from very subtle things,
just as you live your life.
So I love movies.
I love visuals.
So I like to watch
a lot of movies.
I like to see shows
and theater, and just
see different forms
of performance.
That's really inspiring for me.
And then, obviously,
listening to music,
and just listening to
music from other parts
of the world and what
people are making outside
of the bubble of LA, New York.
And yeah, I mean,
people inspire me.
And I think, like I
said, the main thing
is just having new experiences
and changing my environment.
So moving out to
this coast, I think,
will be a very
different experience,
different kind of inspiration
than you get in New York.
And so I'm looking
forward to that and to see
how that influences the sound.
SPEAKER 1: Well, besides "Crawl
Space," which is amazing,
what album should we
listen to that you,
right now, you just
can't stop listening to?
TEI SHI: That's a tough--
I always forget
everything when I
have people ask me about
what music I'm listening to.
SPEAKER 1: It's OK
to say "Crawl Space."
[LAUGHTER]
TEI SHI: Let's see what
I've been listening to.
I feel like I've
said this when people
ask me this question a
lot over the past year,
but there's this album by--
he's Canadian, actually.
Andy Shauf, Shauf, is his name.
And he's a multi-instrumentalist
singer-songwriter, produces
and engineers
everything he does.
He's one of those--
just completely does
everything himself.
And his album
called "The Party,"
it's a concept album about--
basically, it takes you through
this party that he goes to.
And he sings the songs
from different perspectives
of the people
attending the party.
And it's really good.
It's really great music.
He's amazing.
And I think he's going
to really blow up.
So you should check
out that album.
SPEAKER 1: Besides us coaxing
you to come back and perform
at Google, do you have
a time when you're going
to be around again, touring?
Or is that not set
too far in the future?
The best way to find
you besides going to LA?
TEI SHI: Yeah.
Touring is always
kind of happening.
It's always just in flux,
depending on what comes up.
Right now it's not a
super touring-heavy time
just because I'm just
writing new material.
But yeah, we'll be doing
stuff probably more
in the end of the summer
and the early fall.
And you can always keep
up with what's going on
on my socials and stuff.
I always post about
shows and all that stuff.
So definitely.
I'm sure we'll be back
in this area soon.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
that'd be great.
Do you mind if we open
it up to some questions,
if anybody has anything
that they're dying to ask?
Not even dying.
No one came prepared.
TEI SHI: Yeah, we got--
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hi.
TEI SHI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I was going
to say, the little sofa
there is repping
Vancouver and Edmonton.
TEI SHI: Oh, amazing.
AUDIENCE: My parents also
moved us to Vancouver
when I was eight, so I
understand this multi-identity
you're talking about.
So I have two questions.
The first one was, to me,
the power of collaboration
is about bringing
something forward
that can be transmuted
or transformed
when other people add
a perspective to it.
But as a singer
and a songwriter,
when you've got a
vision for something,
when you bring it
forth to other people,
how do you manage
that collaboration,
how do you disagree
productively if people
are taking it in a direction
that isn't what you had wanted?
And the second
question I had was--
so one of the songs on "Crawl
Space" that I've been listening
to on repeat is "Creep."
And I think you've made so
many interesting choices
with the distorted guitars
and all of the stuff.
So how do you retain that vision
when you're doing a smaller,
not-electronic set?
TEI SHI: Woo.
OK.
That's a really good question.
So for the first
part, collaboration
is something that is completely
dependent on the people that
are involved in the dynamic.
And the process is
always different.
But I think with writing
and making music,
making something new with
someone, it's very kind of easy
to gauge when you first
are in a room with someone
and trying to do something kind
of where that's going to go,
and whether your vision or
your opinion is something
that they're going to
help bring to life,
or whether they're
bringing their own thing
and they're kind of just
shutting your ideas out.
So I think the first
phase is always
kind of figuring out
whether the dynamic works.
And then from that
point, it really
just depends on the
people involved.
A lot of the times, I like to
bring a song idea to someone
and have the bones of the song--
the melodies, and the vocals,
and the lyrics-- and the song
written somewhat.
And then build on that.
And usually, for me,
the way I like to work
is to show whoever I'm working
with what I've been inspired
by lately and what I'm
listening to, and kind of just
give them a taste of, I guess,
my mood board, let's say,
of what I'm into or what I want
to bring into this song, what
I want to reference.
And usually we'll just
listen to a bunch of stuff
and go back and forth.
And then it kind of just
happens really naturally.
But I think it's just about
finding the right person who
understands who you are, and
understands where you're coming
from, and your
background, and then
who is willing to
explore with you
but also let you
lead the way as well.
That's, I think,
for me, the best way
that collaboration can work.
And then your second
question, which I'm now,
like, blanking on--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TEI SHI: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's tough.
It's tough translating,
especially because
with the recorded music,
you spend so much time
creating something.
This album I worked
on throughout a pretty
drawn out period of time.
And so the songs, over time,
became these very solidified
things that were, to
me, their own worlds
that I didn't really
want to step outside of.
So on the one hand,
making the live show--
we have a full, live band
that we play the show with,
so we're able to really
stay true to the recordings,
but give them that
live, played element.
But when it comes to
really stripping things
down like this, actually,
I haven't done a ton of it
and we've kind of just
been figuring it out
as we go with this album.
But I think it's really about
letting the songwriting,
letting the melody
and the vocal kind of
sit where it sits in a
way that you can identify.
It feels like the same
song, but also arranging it
in a way with the guitar
giving it a different feel,
changing some of the
chords, or giving
the song a different feeling
and a different pace,
but letting the vocal kind
of carry the song the way
you know it.
And yeah.
I mean, it's fun.
It's hard to actually
attempt to translate
everything that's going on
in a recording with this.
But I think that this experience
has actually kind of informed
my songwriting now, too.
I think about that a
little bit more now
when I'm writing new material.
How is this going
to translate if it's
just a guitar and vocal?
And it's made me focus more
on the songwriting and really
making a song that, it feels
like it can stand on its own
with just a guitar
and doesn't really
need all of that production to
feel like it has an identity.
Yeah.
Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Got anybody
else coming out, coming up?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm usually
on the other side,
so I hope the sound
is acceptable.
[LAUGHS] Tei Shi--
I'm assuming it's a
derivative of your last name.
Is there any special
story behind it?
Is it a nickname?
Or--
TEI SHI: Not really.
It's kind of just an abstract
take on my last name.
And yeah, it just kind of popped
into my head and it stuck.
There's no big
meaning behind it.
AUDIENCE: Choosing a name is
one of the hardest things to do.
TEI SHI: Yeah, exactly.
I think you just kind of have
to throw something at the wall
and just let it--
yeah.
[LAUGHS] Yeah, sorry, there's
no good story behind that.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
I have a question
about the story behind the
child on "Crawl Space,"
the person who comes in there.
Is that you?
And if not-- those
are recordings of you.
That's interesting.
Did you feel embarrassed to
put in the part about how you
wanted to be Britney Spears?
Because it's totally valid.
TEI SHI: No.
SPEAKER 1: I understand.
TEI SHI: So
throughout the album,
there's these little
snippets of tape recordings.
So kind of around
that same time--
I talked about when
we moved to Canada--
I started learning how to
record myself on a cassette tape
just on a boom box my
sister passed down to me.
And she kind of showed me
how I could record myself.
And so I would just sing and
make up songs, and also just
kind of talk to myself.
It became kind of like
a diary type thing.
And so I had these tape
cassettes sitting around
forever.
And I found them when I
was working on the album,
and so I integrated some
parts of them into the album.
And yeah, so that's me just
kind of talking to myself.
For the most part,
at that point,
I really dreamed of being
a singer and a performer,
but I was very young and the
idea I had of being a singer
was Britney Spears.
That was kind of the female
performer/singer when I was
young that I was looking to.
So there was a lot of me
talking about Britney Spears
and how I wanted to be
a singer really badly.
But then also kind of really
kind of beating myself up
about how I wasn't good
enough and I had to be better.
And it was just funny to
me to listen back on those
and see that I was going
through these very ups
and downs and
these insecurities,
but also these big
ambitions that I
think I can still really relate
to at this point in my life.
And yeah.
So they resonated with
me, especially at the time
when I was making
the album and just
kind of dealing with this
weird idea of putting myself
completely out there and
wanting to be better.
SPEAKER 1: So could we assume
then that somewhere out there
are recordings of you
singing Britney Spears?
[LAUGHS]
TEI SHI: Oh yeah,
there's a lot of that.
I didn't include any of the
parts where I was singing.
Yeah, the parts on the
album are just spoken parts.
But yeah, there's a [LAUGHS]
lot of Britney Spears,
Mariah Carey, all that stuff.
SPEAKER 1: So you have
one song and only one
that's in all Spanish.
A lot of music in
the United States
is only in English,
for the vast majority.
There are a good
following for other forms.
But was there any question
about doing that song--
should I have that in there?
Or was that something
like, this song is great,
I need to put it in there,
I want to represent this?
TEI SHI: Yeah.
I mean, I never really
thought about it as like an,
oh, this is in Spanish
and that's a thing.
I had written that song and I'd
had that song floating around.
Actually, I think
that's probably
one of the first songs I wrote
that ended up on the album.
And I had it floating
around for a long time,
and I wanted to do
something with it.
And as I worked on it and
finished it, I really loved it.
And I thought it fit into
the sound of the album
but it also presented
another side that's
a little more organic-sounding.
There's more live
instrumentation on it.
And also, my Spanish,
my Latin background
is a really big
part of who I am,
and I always wanted to write and
release more music in Spanish.
I just was kind of
waiting to write something
that I wanted to put out, and
that just happened to be that.
But yeah.
Yeah, I never really
thought about it too much.
Once I decided it was
going to be on the album,
it was on the album.
And I think I've really enjoyed
being able to sing in Spanish
and also have people that
come to the shows who
speak Spanish sing along.
And they really love that
song, because they can relate
to it in a different way.
And I'll definitely be putting
out more music in Spanish.
That kind of opened
the doors, I think.
SPEAKER 1: Nice.
And I think you have
one more song for us.
TEI SHI: Yeah, we're actually
going to play that song.
SPEAKER 1: Oh.
Lucky me.
TEI SHI: So thank you
for presenting that song.
SPEAKER 1: Well, with that.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
TEI SHI: So this song
is called "Como Si."
[CLEARS THROAT]
[GUITAR PLAYING]
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Once again,
thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Tei Shi.
TEI SHI: Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
SPEAKER 1: Want to also
mention Bobby on the guitar.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]